let's get you up to speed of the latest
developments in the coronavirus pandemic
the total of confirmed coronavirus cases
worldwide has now surged past 50 million
following record numbers of new cases in
several countries including russia and
brazil
the u.s has the most cases with nearly
10 million people testing positive it's
reporting more than a hundred thousand
new cases a day
over the last week and argentina has
signed a deal with drug maker
astrazeneca to deliver around 22 million
doses of vaccines
the aim is for the vaccines to be
available in the first half of next year
to belgium now where the health care
system has been in crisis mode for days
with
covert patients being transported across
the country and even abroad to find
available
intensive care beds marina strauss and
rosie burchard
report the start of a journey that could
help save lives
this belgian covet 19 patient is about
to be transferred
to a hospital in germany first patient
for today is
quite easy for us because he's not
intubated he's not say that
so he's breathing but we have to monitor
everything
heart heartfelt uh so cardiac frequency
blood pressure the consciousness of the
patient
and everything so that's a little bit
challenging in
such a small helicopter 59 year old
freddie needs intensive care support
with the wards filling up here in yesh
he volunteered for transfer to munster
in northwest germany
because he can speak german he gets
how are you i'm fine thank you
during transport freddie wears the
breathing mask
this plastic covering is meant to
protect him
and everyone around him belgium has
become the
epicenter of europe's second coronavirus
wave
lies in the french-speaking part of the
country has been hit especially hard
there are too many sick people and not
enough bats
doctors here fear they soon have to
decide who will get treated
and who won't we are european countries
and we normally have all we need to save
patients
we don't want to do worse than we
usually do at the moment we're still
managing but our biggest fear is that in
a couple of weeks
we'll no longer be able to cope
to help prevent such a situation belgium
has asked germany to take over 19
patients like freddie
at the moment infection rates are much
lower in germany
than here in belgium but the situation
is unpredictable and could change
at any time we are very happy that we
can help
at this moment in time we still have
capacity and belgium capacity capacities
are nearing
uh the possibilities so good that we can
help now and as
in the said perhaps in the future
germans have to come to belgium so it's
all the question of european solidarity
it's good neighborhood and it's really
close cooperation
in just over an hour freddie and the
crew will have arrived on the other side
of the border
providing some relief for the hospital
here in liege
which is now able to take in another
corvette 19 patient
germany is marking one week since
authorities tighten restrictions on
public life for a second time
to fight the spread of the coronavirus
bars and hotels are
shut restaurants are open for takeaway
only but schools remain open
dw had a look around berlin to see how
people are handling the situation
berlin alexanderplatz in the popular
areas for shopping and strolling a safe
distance is not guaranteed so the
politicians
[Music]
that's why there are compulsory masks
even outside
that's i find it terrible why should i
put on a mask out here now
when nobody's walking behind me you have
to be able to breathe fresh air
oh no i do not find it okay that the
mask has to be put on in certain places
because i mean that it's really the
outdoors what is actually that's
supposed to happen there
in public buildings i understand metro
train everywhere
but not here in a public square
do politicians need to explain more
clearly what they're doing to combat the
pandemic
the whole thing doesn't only depend on
the politicians
the whole thing here is a social duty
like many others
in a democracy all people have to
support it in some form
or another in the long run we will have
to live with this virus somehow
and we actually need a social debate how
it's going to look exactly
if we compare the situation in germany
with other countries
then we're relatively okay
don't talk so much something has to be
pushed through now
we have to look at the end of the day to
see what happens
which indicates that the measures are
the right ones
or what comes out at the end will it go
on like this
will the wave get higher and higher then
of course one has to ask the question
doing even more hardly possible for the
restaurants and cafes in the capital
they have to close for a month again
this can be seen almost five kilometers
away in the trendy district of
friedrichshain
[Music]
there are usually hundreds of people in
this pub district
[Music]
tourists but also berliners
[Music]
berlin is a seizure height
berlin needs these security measures to
put down the virus and disease
i work in the hotel business myself and
my hotel is also closed
yes
as long as it's only till november it's
fine november is
danish i think everyone who is not
affected is fine with it
so i don't have any big problems to do
without now for a while
but also only because i don't work in
the hospitality industry and have
nothing to do with it
i can understand that people are angry
or insecure and that it
directly affects them professionally at
the same time
most restauranteurs have invested a lot
of money in hygiene measures
some offer food to go to earn at least a
little money